hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in book two part
three section three of his treatise on
human nature David Hume is going to
present his rather controversial views
on the capacity for reason or rational
faculty including the understanding to
provide some sort of motivation or
direction to the will which is the
Faculty of choice which then leads to
action and David Hume is going to oppose
his view to what we might call a
standard position or standard view that
he takes pretty much everyone prior to
him to have espoused in one way or
another so here's what he says nothing
is more usual in philosophy and even in
common life than to talk of the combat
of passion and reason to give the
preference to reason what does that mean
to give the preference to reason it
means that we evaluate ourselves in
terms of whether we are following
rationality and whether we have
developed our rationality insofar as we
have we're virtuous are good insofar as
we're not perhaps we've developed it but
we're not following rationality were bad
or vicious and he goes on and says every
rational creature tis said this is by
the stand
view is obliged to regulate his actions
by reason so you should do the sorts of
things that everyone else who's a
rational being would likewise do your
motivation should be rationally
explicable to other people they should
be worked out in a rational fashion and
and you should stick to that and he says
if any other motive or principle
challenge the direction of his conduct
he ought to oppose it till it be
entirely subdued or at least brought to
conformity with that superior principle
so if I desire something that I know is
irrational like say a fifth helping at a
meal that's been going on for two hours
or two you know drink myself into a
stupor or you know any one of many other
things that is really you know from some
respect irrational I should follow what
reason says and I should use my force of
will that reason has informed too you
know
impose itself upon that unruly passion
and say no no to it now Hume says that
really doesn't work why well he tells us
that he's going to prove two things in
this section one of these is that reason
alone can never be a motive to any
action of the will now that word alone
is very important he's not saying that
reason doesn't play any role in
motivating our will but reason alone
cannot move anything and in saying that
you know he's not completely original
because Aristotle said something sort of
similar in the de anima in claiming that
mind by itself doesn't move us to action
but it has to have our exes or desire or
appetite however you want to translate
it working as well so that's one thing
that he's going to prove he says also
that it can never oppose passion in the
direction of the will so if there's
reason saying one thing and passion
saying another the will is actually
going to be motivated or directed or
however you want to put it it's going to
be determined in favor of what the
passion is suggesting rather than what
reason is suggesting here we're mostly
interested in this discussion but why it
is that reason alone can't be a
sufficient motivator to the will
why can't knowing something or
understanding something by itself be
enough to make us do something or to
refrain from doing something so Hume has
this distinction that he makes between
different ways in which we are working
with and connecting ideas and he talks
about two main types of reasoning here
that he's considering and he says the
understanding exerts itself in two
different ways as it judges from
demonstration or probability
demonstration what he's calling that
here he has to do with what he calls the
abstract relation of ideas so
mathematics provides a perfect example
of this but we can think of many other
types of things as well logic the
definitions and language these are all
abstract relations of ideas and these
don't motivate us to action by
themselves they're never he says the
cause of any action whatsoever he says I
believe it's scarce will be asserted the
first species of reasoning is ever the
cause of any action its proper Provinces
the world of ideas the will places us
within that of realities demonstration
and volition seem on that account to be
totally removed from each other now
that's not to say that the things that
we do by this for example mathematics
couldn't be useful in the world he says
mathematics are useful in mechanical
operations arithmetic in almost every
art and profession but but they don't
have any influence by themselves he said
gives you an example here a merchant is
desirous of knowing the sum total of his
accounts with any person now is it's an
idle curiosity he just wants to have the
numbers straight why does he want to
have the numbers straight why does he
care about that
well because there's something more than
mere abstract reasoning going on he
actually wants to be in the black as we
say instead of in the red he wants to be
able to spend his money he perhaps looks
forward to retirement or a vacation or
perhaps he's angry at somebody who
hasn't paid back his debts
so he says abstract or demonstrative
reasoning never influences our actions
but only as it directs our judgment
concerning causes and effects so insofar
as it helps us figure out the relation
between causes and effects it might have
something to do with action but by
itself it doesn't do anything like that
what about reasoning about matters of
experience what Hume calls here
probability or in other places moral
reasoning you know the sort of reasoning
about getting things done or avoiding
something here he says that we're
looking at things that involve pain and
pleasure and pain and pleasure in a very
broad sense he says it's obvious that
when we have the prospect of pain or
pleasure from any object we feel a
consequent emotion of a version or
propensity we if we think that something
is gonna be painful or damaging to us we
want to stay away from it we're averse
to it if we think that something is
going to be pleasurable for us we have a
bent towards it that in other places we
can call desire so desire and aversion
pain and pleasure now these are what
Hume calls emotions or passions or we
might say broadly speaking effectivity
so he tells us it's obvious that this
emotion does not rest here but making us
cast our view on every side comprehends
whatever objects are connected with its
original one by their relation of cause
and effect so you know let's use a
childhood examples I placed my hand on
the hot object that's glowing red and
man that hurts like hell and I say I'm
gonna do that in the future I see that
other burning plate over there
I'm not gonna touch that as many think
I'm gonna sit over here quite far away
from it I pop some candy in my mouth and
I like the taste of that and I say
there's some more candy over there how
would I go help myself to that and I
that motivates me to action and in doing
so there's a kind of a natural tendency
but we can also reason about that we can
employ our faculty reason or
understanding to try to produce more
experiences of that sort and to think
you know out in advance wait a second
this might be one of those sort of
things that looks good but is actually
quite painful I better Mull this over so
he says reasoning takes place to
discover this relation according to
their reasoning varies or actions
receive a subsequent variation but as he
says in this case it's emotion not
reason that is providing the impulse
that is determining our will reason is
functioning like a sort of tool a very
high level capable advanced tool but a
bit a tool nonetheless for the desires
or passions or emotions that we are
being driven by he says that tis from
the prospect of pain or pleasure that
the aversion of propensity arises these
emotions extend themselves to the causes
and effect of that object
how insofar as they are pointed out to
us by reason and experience so we do
engage in some investigation reason can
point out the causes and effect it's
going to have to rely upon experience of
course if it's not it's merely doing
this reasoning about abstract relations
of ideas and it can't go very far
according to him demonstrative reason
and can't really do that but there's
this sort of causal or moral or
probabilistic reasoning can actually
take us quite far in understanding
causes and effect of what makes us feel
good or makes us feel bad so he says
when the objects themselves though don't
affect us then their connection can
never give them any info
it's plain that reason is nothing but
the discovery of this connection because
of this I cannot by its means cannot be
by its means that the objects are able
to affect us so reason is not able to on
its own produced a movement to or fro
from anything and there always has to be
some sort of desire effectivity emotion
passion something motivating us already
in the background now he does point out
a little bit later that reason can in
fact help us out with with some things
he talks about for example the moment we
perceive the falsehood of any
supposition or the insufficiency of any
means our passions yield to our reason
without any opposition it gives an
example I may desire some fruit as of an
excellent relish that means it tastes
good but whenever you convince me of my
mistake my longing ceases so so reason
which can help us figure out the means
to satisfy the end of our desires can in
fact tell us this object is not a good
object for us to be desiring but it
can't tell us not to desire we're still
going to want the sweet relish of the
the fruit we're just going to displace
it onto something else
not that fruit maybe that fruit right so
reason by itself according to Hume
although it's a quite powerful tool it
can carry us very interesting you know
wrastlin you know some reasonable
inferences and figure out the causes and
effects and align means and ends and
carry out all those sort of operations
it can't actually motivate us to choose
something or to pursue or to avoid or
even to value something that relies on a
different Faculty of ourselves the
faculty that encounters and senses and
remembers and deals with pain and
pleasure aversion and desire so reason
by its
can't do what the standard view wants it
to do according to him
you